il a qu'un qui est célèbre dans le monde
entier pour ses petits cailloux
des saphirs
un commerce que les habitants font en
plein jour dans la rue
les touristes de passage ne manque pas
de faire une halte pour y acheter des
bijoux pourtant il y a quelques années
les autorités déconseillaient aux
voyageurs de s'y arrêter
il y à 12 ans cette ville était le
centre d'une ruée sans précédent
nous avions posé notre caméra au coeur
de ce far west moderne
il ya un an et demi c'était un arrêt
d'autobus il y avait sept maisons de
terre et 85 habitants
aujourd'hui c'est la capitale du saphir
il a qu'a qui était alors un bidonville
dangereux où les armes circulent est au
grand jour
les acheteurs étrangers principalement
thaïlandais craignaient les attaques de
bandits
[Musique]
les malgaches ne sont pas les grands
gagnants de ce boom dès les premières
heures les étrangers se sont emparés du
marché
en 2000 quand le plus gros négociants de
la région venaient faire des achats ils
sont entourés de précautions maximales
proches au monde bernard stalter stein
et suisse il a été attaqué une fois
c'était en tanzanie on lui avait volé
500 mille francs en chose depuis il se
méfie vous avez
il ya tous les semaines attaques contre
des thaïlandais contre les sri lankais
des acheteurs type r
werner amène du cash à chaque voyage
huit cent mille francs français une
fortune ici les 7 km qui séparent
l'aéroport de la ville sont les plus
dangereux c'est là que les acheteurs
s'installer que les prospecteurs
viennent tenter de vendre leurs
trouvailles ils ont tous entendu l'avion
de werner c'est un bon acheteur même les
petites pièces intéressent
les mineurs se battait pour lui vendre
leurs pierres
en peu de temps werner on achetait un
maximum les malgaches ignorait alors
leur valeur abusant de la naïveté des
prospecteurs aux premières heures de la
ruée vers les saphirs il a gagné
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
cela fait bien longtemps qu'il ne vient
plus à madagascar
aujourd'hui les négociants étrangers
dominent toujours le marché ils ne
viennent plus en avion la plupart vit
sur place la quasi-totalité des mines du
négoce est détenu par les sri lankais à
80%